OK.
This is a huge deal, so we're going to spend
some time on this.
Donald Trump admitted during one of his weekend
press briefings from his club in Bedminster,
New Jersey, where he gathered a crowd of supporters
to cheer for him during a press briefing and
to boo reporters.
I mean, this is complete.
The country is backwards right now.
OK.
He said he is going to be permanently cutting
funding to Social Security and Medicare.
How did he say it?
Take a look.
Because it might not be obvious if I'm victorious
on November 3rd.
I plan to forgive these taxes and make permanent
cuts to the payroll tax.
I'm going to make them all permanent.
Wait a second.
Did he say Social Security there?
What is this about Social Security?
Let me explain it to you.
Donald Trump is finally admitting here that
if he is reelected, he will permanently cut
the employee side of the Social Security deduction
from wages.
This is how Social Security is funded.
This is a huge red alert.
This is not getting the attention it deserves.
And what's crazy is you still have some people,
including people on the left, saying Biden
will cut your Social Security if he's president.
Not something Biden has even talked about
for 27 years, since 1993, during which he
said he wouldn't preemptively take it off
the table.
This is Donald Trump saying, I am going to
permanently reduce the money that is the primary
funding source for Social Security.
So let's talk it through earlier in the pandemic.
Donald Trump started talking
about waiving the so-called payroll tax for
employees through the end of the year.
That tax is shared between you and your employer.
If you are self-employed, you pay all of it.
But for most people, there are W-2 employee,
for example, like producer Pat Pat pays seven
point six five percent out of his salary.
And then I put in another seven point six
five percent.
For him, it's a total of fifteen point three
percent.
It's mostly Social Security and a little bit
for Medicare.
That's how we fund Social Security.
So Trump floats the idea, hey, pandemic economics
or disaster?
Let's put more money in people's pockets by
cutting the seven point six five percent paid
by the employee.
Immediately, the employees get to keep another
seven point six five percent from every paycheck.
Great.
But the way that it was originally conceived
was a deferral, meaning
you get that money in your paycheck through
the end of the year.
But when you file your taxes in 2021 for 2020,
you owe that back.
It was just a deferral.
It gets added back in wasn't even permanent.
It's a temporary savings and then you get
a bill for it.
Now, Trump is again going for the payroll
tax idea.
He's looking at it via executive order, which
he said when Barack Obama was president is
being overused, that he wouldn't do things
through executive order, he'd do them through
legislation, except he's not doing it.
But except he says he'll give you the payroll
tax deferral for now.
If he's reelected, he will forgive the repayment
of the payroll tax.
We think I mean, it's so convoluted that even
Trump has gone back and forth on some of these
points.
But now, again, he says in the future, if
he's reelected, he will just cut the employee
side altogether.
Here he is saying it again.
If I'm victorious on November 3rd, I plan
to forgive these taxes and make permanent
cuts to the payroll tax.
I'm going to make them all permanent.
I plan to forgive these taxes and make permanent
cuts.
This is a shadow plan to cut Social Security
and Medicare.
This is a red alert.
Republicans already say Social Security's
in trouble.
It's underfunded.
It won't be able to pay benefits.
What do you think happens if you cut the money
going in?
You obviously will have to cut the benefits.
So now we have a dramatically different proposal
from Donald Trump versus Joe Biden on Social
Security.
Trump wants permanent cuts to Social Security
taxes, meaning he will have to lower Social
Security benefits.
He's looking to neuter Social Security, a
fabric of our country.
Really, it's I mean, you know, other countries
have much stronger social safety nets.
One of the things we have, one of the few
things is Social Security.
Trump wants to neuter it.
Biden wants to uncap Social Security taxes
above 400000 dollars.
Normally, you only pay payroll tax on the
first hundred and thirty thousand or so of
earnings.
That means if you normally earn a million
dollars, you only paid the Social Security
tax on the first hundred and thirty K above
that, you pay zero.
Biden's idea is you pay on the first hundred
and thirty.
There's then like a donut hole between 130
and 400.
But starting at 400000.
A year in income uncapped.
You pay that seven point six, five percent.
That's a huge increase in funding for Social
Security versus Donald Trump, saying he will
permanently defund it.
This is a topic which is not getting huge
airtime right now.
And we need to force it to get more attention.
Hopefully, it will be a big part of the debates
between Trump and Biden if they happen, because
it is of such huge significance to the vast
majority of the United States.
Just think back.
Trump was supposedly the economic populist,
big populism, wonderful populism from Donald
Trump.
He is now saying if you reelect him, he will
neuter permanently Social Security.
And you can take to the bank the realization
that shortly thereafter they're are going
to say, hey, we gave you the payroll tax.
People are getting the money out front.
But we're going to have to cut Social Security
benefits as a result.
We're no longer funding it to the extent that
we previously were.
Don't allow this issue to be ignored.
Democrats need to run hard with this all the
way to November.
And you know that Republicans would do the
exact same thing if Democrats suggested even
smaller changes to programs they believe are
important.
This is an attempt at a massive destruction
of one of the most important programs that
exists in the United States to even maintain
financial solvency for so many millions of
Americans once they hit retirement